it's 5 43 hispanics are the country's
second largest ethnic group in the
latest 2020 u.s census this morning
we're checking out a new art exhibit
preserving hispanic heritage it involves
the colorful papal picado or cut paper
hector mejia is live near 4th and clark
in downtown las vegas with a look inside
good morning hector how did i do now you
say it so well
[Music]
fantastic hey there sherry good morning
to you so this technique has rich
history in mexico and it takes a lot of
work to pull this off just take a look i
usually done with a pair of scissors or
a knife and this is tissue paper some
really fragile tissue paper but it's so
festive and so colorful and that's what
the exhibit is all about here at the
historic fifth street school mayor's
gallery and check out this giant avocado
just imagine how much guacamole you can
make with an avocado this size of one
actually existed so this place is open
tuesdays through fridays from 2 p.m to 6
p.m this exhibit highlighting local
artist justin favela and it's a pretty
long narrow hallway here we have other
artwork here all done by the same artist
here to highlight hispanic heritage
month and it's just one of many ways the
city of las vegas is celebrating this
special month we'll be talking a bit
more about other celebrations across the
state across the city in the next hour
for now reporting live hector mejia live
local now back to you guys
all right well hey we're